[Music]
serious a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us CBS
this morning Saturday co-host Michelle
Miller recently met identical twin
sisters from Grand Rapids Michigan
the twins are alike in almost every
single way except for one thing Michelle
good morning good morning that's a
mouthful isn't it well Marcus barks and
Jessica and Tyson have overcome the odds
and are now looking to serve their
communities the twins are running for
office and adjoining districts in Kent
County Michigan but that's as John said
where the similarities end we've been
rolling together for a long time
identical twins Monica sparks and
Jessica Ann Tyson finish each other's
sentences
what I'm saying hate to run against me
and bicker like most siblings and she's
bossy oh no wait
okay you have to ask our mom our mom can
tell you she's the boss I get that you
both think the other is bossy so I want
to know when did you realize that your
political affiliation had diverged I
hope I can earn your vote that's right
Monica Sparks is a Democrat Hey how are
you today Jessica Ann Tyson a Republican
you write as good yes I do
that's your dear vehicle of choice well
it helps me to get around to more houses
and the twins are running for the same
position in neighboring Michigan
districts when she told our dad that she
was running as a Republican our dad said
you got to be cotton-picking kidding me
I mean he almost fell off his chair it's
funny because I say I stand with the
Democratic Party for civil rights
Liberty justice for all equality and
equity and she says the same thing about
the Republican Party so I think we just
see through a different lens so what is
it about the county commissioner seat
that you see the possibility to make a
difference I don't see it as a seat I
say that I'm running to serve not take a
seat thank you and I hope I can earn
your boat
the sisters feel called to serve after a
difficult childhood including a mom who
battled addiction and abuse in the
foster care system
we had one mattress we slept on I
remember no cover we would have to
decide like who would try to get the
cereal on top of the refrigerator so now
you're going into the night and then you
wake up and you still can't get that box
of cereal so Monica would go out and she
would look in trash cans when they were
8 years old Monica and Jessica Ann were
adopted into a loving home where they
learned to embrace their individuality
and find common ground
our mom never let us argue our goal was
if we did have a difference of opinion
we had to do research on it so she had
to research my point I had to research
my point and then we'd come together and
try to figure out a solution
the Twins may belong to opposing
political parties but their message
transcends labels the left wing and the
right wing belong to the same bird I can
like someone and not appreciate their
policies and that's what I do with her
every day do people see you together I
mean all the time I do yeah if they both
win the sisters would serve side-by-side
on the Board of Commissioners we have a
goal a common goal to serve the people
we're not gonna agree on a hundred
percent of everything but if we can find
50% 60% even 30% to agree on then let's
work on those things that we can agree
on and then we'll try to figure out the
rest later it's not gonna split you two
up no no absolutely not well the primary
election is on August 7th the twins
admit that they would actually endorse
get this each other's own opponents no
yes they sat there and so I'm surprised
to hear that
yes but the left wing and the right wing
belonged to the wood ain't they always
dress alike when they're together not
always and I bet they do enough and I
would think if you're running for
two separate platforms that you would
want to differentiate yourself but they
say they do they feel this story cries
for a follow-up on August 7th thanks
Michelle thank you